you can think of arrow site is being
game film for business I realized that
businesses might be able to benefit from
putting cameras into the workplace in
the same exact way that professional
sports teams use video to prepare for
sporting events we built up a lot of
credibility in the media industry the
processing plants have really
significant concerns around sanitation
so as to prevent ecoli in the first year
that they use our services they lower
their coli rates by sixty percent the
next market we chose was health care my
dad who is a physician up in Boston said
this is really important you need to
bring this into the health care industry
so we tried and no one would even look
at a pilot a free pilot privacy was a
really big concern we need to
de-identify not just patients but
workers fundamentally take patient
privacy and employee privacy completely
off the table and so we thought about it
and we said you know maybe we could just
dial down the resolution of the entire
image and loan the hold even with the
lower resolution where you can't make
out anybody's face or anything revealing
you can see the extremely important
safety protocols that they have to
follow that help prevent surgical site
infections it work terrifically all the
work that we've been doing in health
care has led to us now having about 12
companies that are multi-billion dollar
clients we have hopes that our services
are going to be brought into retail
paper plants schools the opportunities
are profound and we're really excited
about where it's going to go
you